time to come home now the words of
Nicola Bully's sister pictured here with
their mum it's been three weeks since
the mum of two vanished nobody knows how
nobody knows where to but from what
police do know we retraced Nicola's
movements as she took her dog Willow for
a walk on their regular route
so Nicola would have come through the
gate
and she would have walked onto what is
now the lower field it was around this
time roughly
about 850 that Nicola was then spotted
by another dog walker yeah someone who
knew her at 8 53 police say right now
three weeks ago Nicola hit send yep and
an email was sent to her boss Nicola
logged in about one minute past nine
yeah she would have held the phone out
of time yeah 9 20 three weeks ago
Nicholas phone had moved to this bench
so police say that the team's call ended
9 30.
but Nicola's phone remained logged on to
that team's call in other words she
hadn't ended the call
just minutes later Ron a dog walker one
of the first people to arrive at the
bench saw only Willow its harness and
Nicholas phone still unlocked
I got something to go to the toilet in
the uh you know that would have been
that was my first I got to feel about
this red brick building here and I uh I
thought this this is not right we found
out a couple of the wallpaper on the
phone we found out who the couple were
then the school was contacted and Paul
arrived it was Paul her partner who
informed police of Nicholas
vulnerabilities her struggled with
alcohol due to the menopause straight
away investigators regarded her as a
high-risk missing person but releasing
this personal private information led to
the Prime Minister raising concerns and
Lancashire police now carrying out its
own internal review well I agree with
the Home Secretary in like her I was
concerned that that private information
was put into the public domain and I'm
pleased that the police are looking at
how that happened in the investigation
the search for Nicola continues today's
sniffer dogs scouring the banks of the
river wire if the police's main theory
is right that she ended up in the water
it's highly likely she's now at sea but
for her family hope hasn't faded just
yet Nicholas father Ernie told us whilst
every day is a struggle we just need a
breakthrough if that comes it will be a
miracle amidst this mystery into man
Rashid Sky News Lancashire